or like i don't know what you're talking
about it's not in my universe because
your universe is different because
you're like look i i'm hyper for my wake
up i'm full of energy and you actually
like you like vibe with that energy uh
when you you go somewhere when you show
up with that energy when you're on the
track you show up the energy when you're
on camera and and you can see it right
like like you've got like a like a
little happy
kind of playful but it's powerful right
and
and you can turn it on
but
most people when they wake up in the
morning they don't know how to turn it
on and i didn't
right and now i know how to turn it on
but it for me i had to fix my sleep
architecture and if you when you look at
your sleep monitor so i have an aura
ring um it's o-u-r-a as the company i've
heard those are the best those i mean
that's what has the best reputation they
they are and i i'm an advisor and
investor in the company so i would i
would say that anyway but uh i wouldn't
lie if it wasn't true i validated this
with dan gartenberg a sleep scientist
from the university of wisconsin who's
gone through with a million dollar grant
and studied this
compared to other things and i really
feel confident that it's the best but is
your watch good enough sure
and
what i recommend people do is track what
you hack if you wake up feeling great
all the time
there's one or two things going on you
could have no awareness you know i think
i'm feeling great but there's 10 levels
above that that you've never accessed
but i don't think that's true for you
right because you wouldn't show up in
your life the way you do if that was the
case so then you don't need to fix your
sleep so don't bother tracking it and go
track something that matters to you
because if you track everything you just
fall in this this pit of oh my god maybe
i didn't do it right am i perfect enough
and it creates anxiety you can just toss
all that track what you hack that's what
i worry about is that with people they
let this be their dictator on whether or
not they have a good day or don't have a
good day in their mind because they're
like oh man i only got
five minutes of rem sleep tonight and i
thought i feel great like i thought i
had a great night's sleep and i just
think that that can be a little bit so
at least we're the best of the wearables
if you're gonna do it um
but but sleep very important i've always
been very perplexed by my sleep and i'm
i know i can be sound like a dick when i
say i don't really need sleep i truly
could i mean i want eight hours i try so
i wish i could get eight hours but
truly my number is more like six and a
half to seven
and that's like me doing great um but i
could pretty well function on
five
okay we're wired the same way um there's
some genetic stuff that there but i'm
going to set you free of that concern
the largest study ever done of sleep was
1.2 million people tracked over three
years
and that is an enormous amount of data
and it's the only one that had enough
granularity to look at the differences
between six and a half versus seven
versus seven and a half versus eight
guess how long the people who live the
longest sleep
eight i would think that's what you
think right they sleep six and a half
hours a night they don't sleep eight
hours a night so you're actually
sleeping the amount of time that a
healthy person sleeps it's not because
less sleep makes you live longer is
because healthy people need less sleep
so if you're getting enough of the right
nutrients you're living in an
environment that's supportive of your
biology
you
it's okay to feel rested and get six and
a half hours of sleep there is really
good data to support that if you sleep
eight hours a night you die more from
all cause than people who sleep six and
a half hours on average and if you need
nine hours of sleep you should really be
careful because the risks of sleeping
nine hours a night of needing to do that
are greater than the risks of sleeping
five and a half hours a night wow okay
so don't push yourself to get eight
hours i don't i don't get eight hours on
weekends i don't need it like i i've
gotten five times this year i've had
more than eight hours of sleep
right and that's okay i sleep six six
and a half hours i'm totally good to go
you've changed my life now in two
different ways one you just told me my
sleep is somewhat ideal
and then the other thing that you told
me when you interviewed me was that i
could eat duck eggs instead of chicken
eggs and i should be fine and
literally like changed my life i mean i
don't i'm running low i only have eight
left right now and i'm like where am i
gonna find a farmer's market but um
but uh but that changed my life so i i
have to say thank you um very much for
that you're so welcome so there's one
other thing i want to talk to you about
and it's it like gets into ethics and
i'm just kind of curious of your
thoughts about it but
i
i my brain has i watched something about
this a few years ago it wasn't the
greatest of docs
then i watched another doc about this
the other day and i thought that's
amazing and i didn't even realize it but
before i watched that about two weeks
ago i bought a book
called codebreaker
and i have i in my mind i'm so curious
about crispr
and i'm kind of curious from your
perspective
what being being a hacker being someone
who's trying to idealize things and
optimize your body
how you know what your thoughts about
crispr art maybe it's
or do you check in do you know about
crispr much
oh yeah okay so maybe explain to people
what it is because again i'm i'm really
scratching the surface with it but i'm
very curious
and then i'm just kind of curious to
hear your thoughts what you think you
know where what what's coming down the
pipeline and if you'd be willing to do
whatever
crispr is a relatively new technology
that lets you edit a specific
gene and take a very small part of it
before we had sort of very primitive
ways of trying to change genetics around
so we can now with precision pull out
just a little bit of this and put a
little bit of something else in
and of course biohackers like me are
saying
wow
maybe we can fix genetic weaknesses that
we have
right and i believe that it's a hundred
percent ethical for us to have full
control of our own biology so if i want
to get giant hoops in my ears i want to
get weird piercings or
heck if i want to remove my left arm for
cosmetic reasons it's my right to do
that it's just dumb okay but it's my
right to be dumb because it's my body
and my body my choice right
so
um
that said i think there are great risks
that some countries are and i actually
interviewed someone about this on my
show a while ago
who couldn't talk about some of it
because of his government connections
but
um
there are countries probably including
the us but certainly some other
countries who are doing that science
fiction were going to use crispr to edit
humans and make super soldiers from the
embryo if you are going to reproduce
right now i don't believe it's ethical
to use crispr to edit your own genome in
a way that could be passed down into our
germline because we just don't know
enough but if you wanted to do
what i'm planning to do
using liz parish's work and she's been
on my show is you can go in and you can
change things things like mtor the
ability to put on muscle you can fix
metabolic problems in my case i'm
relatively sensitive to environmental
toxins like toxic mold because of
something called hla dr4 can i edit
those with crispr not yet but will i and
and would i yes
and in fact i'm talking about that at
the biohacking conference september 17th
in orlando
i've been putting this conference on
every year and i invite people who are
doing potential gene editing for humans
right now is to treat diseases but dying
of old age is a disease and i want to
treat aging with crispr so i think it's
going to happen but for i don't think we
have a right to do it in a way that
makes us pass it down to our offspring i
do know one very wealthy person who did
go through
and
i don't believe he used crispr he used
another technique but basically removed
cystic fibrosis from his germline
and he did that this is a very wealthy
individual
because most people couldn't do that and
also there's secrecy and stuff
but overall i um
i'm not concerned
about
someone doing something stupid to
themselves because we do crazy things
you know what we do sometimes we get in
cars when we drive really really fast
where you might hit a wall
that's okay but it's not okay to like
get healthier with something